始めまさかの場でを着てたりわー
起きてますよこんばんはドクター外れですネットのニュースなんちょびっと話題になっ
ていたものがありますあぁ
生菌さんが2週間前に行ってますね熱帯がかぶってしまいました
刃開くのを見るツイートいうことが売っていたので買ってみました
結構昔からあるんだろう食べて寝ると奇妙な夢を見る悪夢どっち
てるとというチーズがあるんですけどもう前ちょっと買ってみました
あの中古屋さんで見つけたんで買ってきました
可愛いですよね
うこれですねこの中に悪夢のチーズが入っています
もう怖いよやとなって保つため用のでしょ
まあがいたって普通のチーズですね薔薇基金は3月まで持つみたいです
てかなんでこれがその悪部が見ると言われてんだろうをボスの範囲であると有利か何
その日はれるんだろうといえばちょっと調べてみましょう
エステルととイギリスイングランド芸さんのチーズの一つ三大ブルーチーズの一つと
言われています
有名なですね知ってたエリザベス女王の大好物としても知られています
別名アーク部のチーズと多いわ
ています食べると変な指を見るという不思議なチーズエッジ大
男性の75%女性の85%が辺の指を見ると言っていたみたいです
寝る30分前に捨てるとチーズのかけらを20g を食べててるだけこれ1個で台で
120g なんてだいたい6分の1くらい食べればいいかな
もうすごいなんか公式が発表
をしているたらチーズ委員会みたいねぇ2がチーズ食べては夢が変わる見ていることを
言ってるみたい
ただ
原因は不明ぞよず40分で今あぁあああ
不吉やお酒と合うみたいですね強い
でもやってみたいというわけであります
パッと見頭のチーズなんてよねそれかチーズてあれでで腐ってるんだよねを兼ねる
チーズがなんだかよくわかんないかな
匂い
もう普通にいい匂いのチーズだこれからかわいいよなぁ
では早速捨てるとチーズ食べていこうと思いますいやー
20g なって
少ないような俺ロボット方面感たまんないけどなく見てたマネーでなくみたいと思っ
てるんでできるだけ食ってみると思います1個くれたら一番いいんですけどどれだけ
食えるか
おれしらいっちー上拾石だからきついと思うんだよなドイツで食べてみますわいただき
ます
うわぁ
me
これ食べ名大人の味だ
うんっ
パケでアクメやチーズって腐ってるんだっけ
謎あいうええっ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ビール名なんかアソビットクラッカーにのせぐらいでこれ見やすだな多分これくらい
もうほんとほんとにプロットアーちゃんにもうちょっとどうすればでいいですよね
ねえな話目だ単品で宮とあのまあ言い方悪くすると進まず買ったんですけどクラッカー
と混ぜるとめちゃくちゃ美味しい
めっちゃ打ったねれ30分前にされなきゃいけないんで僕はもこれを喰え次第早々に寝
ます
んーやっぱチーズとを避けてああ
あれ
ねっ
ごめんもうもう行ったらに頭が水は書く前に食っております半分は行ったかなわかん
ないけど結構食ったと思います悪夢を見るかどうかよくわからんですけど普通に
美味しかった酢酒が後クラッカーんでは
ねますもうこのような30分以内に寝るって書いてあったんですぐ出て起きてからの僕
の夢の感想+出てる間にフードからに言えばないかも含めて
とっていこうと思います覚えてみなさいああここはもう俺が強悪夢のチーズを食べて
から30分以内なので選んだから寝ると奇妙な弓を wiki と
作れていこうと思いますおやすみなさいん
[音楽]
お前やー
いい
[音楽]
はいおはようございますあの旗 by てビール飲んだから弾いてや
結果から言いますど本当に奇妙な夢を見ました
な夢ってさあねダンスよねなんか曖昧だから具体的な言葉で覚えてないんですけど
とりあえずまず奇妙な夢だ
敵がそそれとレアの元 smap の中居くんがいましたで学生時代の話だった気がし
ます
でなんかすごい
楽しかった夢でした
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ